Hãy quân bà nước Trung Quốc, nhà bà Iran em muốn muối thamut, bắt đầu một tôn tập trận Trung tại của Việt Nam Phi trong quân cộ hạt động Martin Rick Loss.
Mú có phòng la phía cho biết của tập trận la Thêm I.C. Hoa Bình Nam Thành, trong hay bây giờ, tập Trung vào cán tội dung như bảo đam át quan hàng hải.
Bảo vệ tuyên bật tại Việt, phối hợp team kìm kìm nạn và nân cao khả năng hiệp đồng giữa các lực lượng hạ quân tham gia.
Giờ chức la phía cho biết tất cả các nước thuộc quân cộ Rick Loss, nếu được môi tham gia trong đó, Brazil, Agap và Etukia,
dự vời từ các quân xa viên, các đổi nà phía nhìn mạnh đây là hỏi độ một lượng thương lệ,
Martin ký thật quân sự không nhằm vào bất kì của gia thứ ba nào.
Fraterallya cũng đồng thời bác bỏ lập lượng dòng, chủ chỉ của tập trận làm suy yếu lập trường chủ lập của Nam Phi.
Nếu này thằng định cũng thương suyên tiền hành tập trận với hà con Mỹ và các đổi tắc tương tay khác,
nhà Iran Trung Quốc tập trận Trung trong bối cảnh tổ chức kênh kinh tình môi nỗi brick chếp tụm mờ rau.
Được các nước thành.